so we have another viewer submitted
question from Leo hi Leo how would an
inexperienced writer enjoy writing if
their writing skills aren't spectacular
but they love the idea they have how do
they not get discouraged and lose
motivation afterward well that's a
definite challenge for all writers is
getting discouraged and losing
motivation you know it's it's really a
mental or psychological game to stay
with it in the face of maybe other
people not being excited about the stuff
that you've written which I think all
writers go through I certainly have gone
through and still go through at times
with stuff that I am writing so you do
have to you know it's this weird
combination of following your passion
and your beliefs and your instincts and
what's interesting to you while also
listening to sort of feedback and
guidance about what makes something
compelling story for others
now some people I suppose can enjoy
writing and not care that anyone else
ever gets it or likes it in that case
you don't have such a problem because
you just I'm writing because I enjoy it
I don't necessarily even show it to
other people but most writers don't want
to just do that they wanted to show it
to others and have others like it well
that's where it's out of our control
suddenly because others are not us right
so it's easy once others don't respond
well to get discouraged but the reality
is every script that anyone has ever
written probably didn't impress many
people on its journey to wherever it got
to in other words it's just hard to
write something rare to write something
that people are gonna give you the
reaction that you wanted from it for
most people starting out that's an
elusive thing to get to that place so
it's kind of like you you have to have
this kind of almost Zen approach of I'm
just doing this anyway I'm learning and
growing and I'm going to get there and
like not let anybody's criticism derail
you from that intense focus on this is
what I want to do and I'm gonna continue
to follow my voice but my voice or my
instincts are going to change somewhat
when I study the craft and when I get
feedback from others and I just look to
make that feedback useful as opposed to
devastating you know what is the thing
that maybe is missing for people in my
work based on the feedback I'm getting
and can I wrap my head around what's
missing and why and apply that
understanding to either the next draft
or the next thing I write for most
people it takes many scripts over many
years to get to the point where you have
a chance at the stuff you're writing
really being successful with others who
might matter to you so I think just also
knowing that every writer goes through
that and there's this book called the
war of art by Steven Pressfield that's a
great one for this because he really
talks about how a part of us is afraid
and resistant to just doing whatever it
is we said we want to do and we'll use
any excuse to not do it including others
criticism or our own self criticism and
it's kind of like to be productive and
to stay with it you just have to sort of
push all that aside and just continue
going and turn the criticism into
something productive instead of letting
it get you down including your own
self-criticism which is really the
hardest the hardest thing I think is to
be able to kind of put that aside use it
when you need to critique and analyze
your work but not always be in the
critical mode because you're in the
critical mode you're not in the creative
mode it's kind of like you have to
switch one off to get to the other the
creative mode is a more loose free open
relaxed trusting mode where ideas just
sort of come but in your if you're in
that mode of what's wrong with it and
what do other people say is wrong with
it and what do I think is wrong with me
ideas generally don't come that are good
ideas in that state so you almost have
to like work on managing your own
emotional state and your own viewpoint
in order to be able to get to your best
material I know I've mentioned this
before but are not updation the two the
two Nikolas KITT you know Charlie
Kaufman and just that the one that's
just invents lightning and the other one
that that just over thinks everything
and how paralyzing that is yeah yeah
Donald Kaufman the brother has a may not
be writing the greatest material but
he's got a positive attitude toward
himself and others that is infectious
and leads to a lot of ideas coming that
do end up being successful in the
context of that movie right but I mean
it's a great because we've seen that so
many times in life where that really
does it's the south
prophecy in either direction and so and
I think writers are especially prone
because they're always in their heads
and they're overthinking things that's
the nature of why they're writers in
some sense angry at but it also can
really handicap them way so do you
remember when you sort of let up on
yourself even if you still deal with you
know I mean we all do seeing ourselves
whether it's you know on tape or
whatever is is always sort of a
cringe-worthy moment for everybody I
think but do you do you remember when
you sort of were able to come to more of
a Zen place with that it's an everyday
practice every day it's a challenge to
feel like to sort of put on the the
right mindset to be creative and to be
sort of like allowing and trusting and
letting go and not being self-critical
to self-critical so it's not a one time
thing that you get to and you're just
like oh I don't do that anymore you may
get more used to how you can shift your
kind of energy into that other mode and
so you have a way to do it but I like
what the war of art would say is that
that resistance that's in you is like
trying to stop you and it will do it
every day it's just like there's a part
of us that's going to be self-critical
to the point of paralyzing or
counterproductive or self sabotaging so
I really do think you have to learn how
to everyday sort of fight the battle or
you know see it for what it is and not
let it just take you over completely in
your thinking so that you have a choice
and can get to that place where you can
move forward but I don't think it ever
like completely just goes away
you